des élections qui signe le divorce entre
deux parties farouchement
indépendantiste d'un côté ensemble pour
la catalogne partie dekyndt aura de
l'autre le rc la gauche républicaine de
catalogne
les deux partis gouvernent la région
ensemble depuis 2016 mais ils sont
tellement en concurrence pour la
suprématie sur le mouvement
indépendantiste que kim torah remettent
en question leur alliance
cette législature n'a plus d'avenir elle
touche à sa fin nous devons retrouver un
sentiment d'unité des stratégies
communes et de lutte partagé qui ont été
écrasés aujourd'hui par des décisions
moins consensuelle et non éclairée à
l'origine de cette volte face
la décision prise par le rci lundi de ne
pas soutenir le président
indépendantiste la gauche républicaine
de catalogne a en effet refusé de
désobéir à un ordre de la commission
électorale celui de priver le président
catalan de son siège de député régional
du côté des catalans
les avis sur le scrutin à venir sont
partagés ces politiciens nous compliquer
la vie
on ne peut pas vivre sans politique mais
on verra s'il commence à prendre la
sphère au sérieux et à gouverner pour
les gens et non pour eux-mêmes
je pense que ces élections sont une
occasion de consolider l'indépendantiste
qui est actuellement un sentiment fort
mais nous avons besoin de plus d'unité
je pense que ces élections quand une
bonne occasion de la consolider il est
clair que je vais très fortement
réfléchir à mon vote
car je pense que nous attendions
beaucoup d'eux et que n'ont pas été très
attentif à nous l'annoncent de ces
élections anticipées intervient peu de
temps avant l'ouverture d'une
négociation entre le gouvernement
central et celui de catalogne
ils doivent discuter du conflit
politique en catalogne
ce vote pourrait avoir des conséquences
imprévisibles sur la stratégie de
détente initiée par pedro sanchez
le chef du gouvernement socialiste le
premier ministre qui doit se rendre à
barcelone le 6 février pour rencontrer
kim torah
[Musique]